[Music]
we had the roman empire the spanish
empire the british empire now we live in
the age of the american empire
[Music]
no other country has had such a military
presence in so many places even in
remote places like guam in the middle of
the pacific america has a military base
and that's actually pretty useful
the fact that you can buy a mobile phone
made in south korea with just
one click that's the outcome of global
capitalism but also global capitalism
would not be possible if trade
wasn't safe those american bases they're
there to protect those ships that
move goods from one place to another and
this is really the reason why the us
invests so much in having a strong army
which
has kind of been unchallenged until now
so you might be wondering or you might
not be who is challenging this empire
because
of course it's china and well how is
china doing it
well that's what we're going to see in
this video
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the million dollar question why
does america have such a big army you
might argue that it doesn't really need
one
in fact just by looking at a map you can
see that america has
a big advantage it's secured by two
fairly sizable oceans making it
almost impossible to attack or invade
nonetheless america has the biggest army
on the planet
it has more than a million active
military personnel
and almost 800 military bases located in
70 different countries territories
all over the globe britain france and
russia by contrast have about 30 foreign
bases
combined
just have a look at this map america is
all over the place
and there is no country that can
challenge them well hold on a second
because
maybe there is yes dear viewers today
we're talking all about china here on
visualpolitik we've talked
thousands of times about china's
economic progress
it's the world's factory and many
chinese companies are starting to become
big competition for the technological
bear moths
but now we're talking about their
military more specifically their
military presence in the south china
sea and believe me this is no joke
[Music]
china's south china sea play the end of
beijing's peaceful rise
the definition string of pearls was
first used in 2005 in an
international report given by the
department of defense of the united
states
in this report it was predicted that
china will try to expand its naval
presence throughout the indian ocean
region
in this context the pearls are a
metaphor for each of the military bases
that china wants to build
making a string that goes all the way
down to africa
and the middle east where china imports
most of its natural resources
and as you can imagine these military
expansions they scared the whole world
especially america and it got even more
scary when the former chinese president
hu jintao said
this in 2009
[Music]
the road of peaceful development is a
strategic choice
made by the chinese government and
people in the line of the nation's
peace-loving traditional culture the
trend of our times and the fundamental
interests of
china hu jintal yeah so for some reason
this quote that was intended to chill
out the americans basically had the
opposite effect it pretty much sounded
like china was saying the opposite
of what is actually the truth but okay i
know what you're probably thinking right
now i mean
so what what's the problem with china
trying to increase their military after
all it's just another country
everyone has an army and wants to be
safe right i mean why should we care
about china having military bases do
they
really want to surpass the united states
can they even
well today we're going to answer all of
those questions but before we do
as we always do let's take a look back
at the history
lessons from the pain yeah we said
america is almost impossible to
invade but there was an exception and
that was in the year 1941 when japan
bombed pearl harbor in hawaii
[Music]
a year later the japanese invaded the
aleutian islands in alaska that was the
moment when america
learned an important lesson nobody is
100 safe it was also the time that they
figured they should probably care about
protecting the oceans
in fact during world war ii the us had
to fight among lots of small islands in
the pacific this was the case during the
battle of midway
after the attack on pearl harbor the
japanese tried to eliminate the us as a
strategic power in the pacific
and they hoped to succeed by
demoralizing the american forces with
another surprise attack american
cryptographers though they managed to
decipher the date and the location of
japan's attack and
prepared a surprise counter-attack
needless to say the u.s
inflicted irreparable damage to the
japanese fleet world war ii ended
the americans won and they remembered
their lesson we can't
let this happen again
so well what did they do well they
covered the pacific ocean with military
bases basically they kept soldiers on
those small
islands where they had fought and now
you might be wondering why is it so
important to have soldiers on a small
island that no one really cares about
i mean is it really that bad if someone
wants to invade an atoll like midway i
mean
really and also moving soldiers to the
other side of the planet and keeping
them there is not
exactly cheap
[Music]
a warship is basically a floating city
with big guns on it and it's a city that
can
travel 500 to 1000 kilometers in one day
so moving one of those from los angeles
to shanghai
would take more than 10 days
[Applause]
but if you already have ships and
soldiers in guam
you can be to shanghai in almost three
days
this is designed to deter potential
conflicts
in fact most of those ships would never
have to fire
a single weapon being so powerful
honestly no one would probably dare to
attack them but not only that many of
these ships are not meant to combat
other armies but rather than meant to
combat pirates for example the uss
independence is a warship created for
the main purpose
of combating piracy and this is just one
of many ships
in fact the uss naval force is getting
bigger and bigger
all the time and this means that so far
no one has been able to match it
[Music]
u.s navy to add 46 ships in five years
but 355 ships won't come for a long time
of course this gives america a huge
amount of power and this can be worrying
to some
people but so far it's created a safe
environment where
everybody can trade untroubled whenever
some country
or some pirates want to block a trade
route they have to face
all those american ships this is one
reason why southeast asian nations have
become exporting powerhouses
and of course it's benefited china too
[Music]
the truth is that there are many
countries that would happily block
china's trade routes but
is china comfortable in this position
does it like depending so much
on america's army well let's have a look
a new hegemon so what defines a
territory well a territory is an
area of land under the jurisdiction of a
ruler or a state
not all territories are born equal some
have abundant natural resources like
gems gas and oil while
others basically have no resources the
availability of some resources gives the
country they belong to some pretty big
advantages in trade the most obvious
example of this
is oil and how much its trade has
defined
saudi arabia's economy
what about the others those who have
little or few resources
they need to import everything for their
industries they must compete with
international bidders to secure stable
supplies of resources
which basically means their industrial
cost of production
is also going to be higher and this this
dear viewer is essentially china's
situation yes china's got a lot of
industry but almost
no resources oil steel uranium most of
the things it needs to make those mobile
phones cars or tvs
it's got to come from other parts of the
world and this appetite for raw
materials is increasing
every single day but this still isn't
the end of our story once those
resources are required china needs to
transport them to its territory safely
and for as little money as possible the
south china sea is the busiest
collection of shipping lanes
in the world it's the lifeblood of east
asia carrying most of its trade and oil
it's obvious then that china would very
much like to keep these lines of trade
open
and preferably to control them
china also doesn't have a big consumer
market like the us does so it wants to
export
a lot of what it makes in order to make
money and these routes can
be blocked at any time by one of their
neighboring countries which would stop
all of that from happening
the communist party the governing force
in china also
has a lot of mouths to feed so control
over this region is essential if the
party wants to stay in power alright so
i can probably guess what you're
thinking right now you're probably
thinking well china isn't the only one
many other countries have no natural
resources either and
they don't complain of course but there
is a big problem here
being so dependent on imports and
exports china only needs
one country to block its roots to
collapse it in a matter of months
and as we mentioned before there are
many countries who would very happily do
that
especially one in particular and that's
india you see this string of islands on
the indian ocean well these belong to
india and the indian army
could block chinese boats there
[Music]
and this would mean that china couldn't
buy most of the oil that they currently
consume
most of the oil tankers that go from the
middle east to china
pass through the strait of malacca right
where singapore is
we're talking about almost 20 million
barrels of oil a day
and many other goods in addition but if
india blocked the roots among those
small islands
good luck trying to get that oil in fact
there is such an existential threat to
china that their former president hujin
tao
used to call this the malacca dilemma
and we're not just talking about
india in fact america isn't going
through their best time when it comes to
loving the chinese either
and again the american navy it has the
capability to block the oil supply to
china
by sea this would be far more
devastating than
any trade war so well what's the
solution
the belt and road initiative and its
maritime counterpart
the string of pearls the belton road
initiative was initiated by president xi
jinping in 2013 with the aim of
rebuilding infrastructure
and accelerating chinese economic growth
essentially this is a brand new silk
road and the string of pearls
well that's its maritime brother in 2017
mr xi pledged an additional 124 billion
dollars
towards his 900 billion belt and road
initiative china is promoting this
global trade infrastructure as a
long-term win-win campaign for the 65
nations that have signed up to it
most western leaders however they stayed
away from the chinese summit announcing
the ambitious project
but the 28 heads of state present at
what mr xi called a gathering of great
minds
included president putin of russia and
president ergodan
of turkey
[Music]
this is indeed a gathering of great
minds in the coming two days i hope that
by engaging in a full exchange of views
we will contribute to pursuing the belt
and road initiative
a project of the century so that it will
benefit people across the world
xi jinping with china consolidating its
power in relationships with countries
all over the south china sea region it
might become
really difficult for the united states
to keep being the big boss in charge of
the region
if china was to surpass the u.s the
united states would lose all of its
deterrence power in this key region of
the globe
and this would completely change the
rules of international trade americans
well they're pretty worried about this
and earlier this year the cia went so
far as to
state that the u.s has two major
problems right now russia
and china and their effort to undermine
the us's influence in key regions like
africa and the south china sea
[Music]
we are not naive and we are taking
significant steps on the
counterintelligence side
so that we have all the defenses that we
need u.s africa command's
general thomas waldhauser all right so i
know what you're thinking you
probably think in america it's an empire
all over the world and we're just
talking about one small region the south
china sea
and yeah that's absolutely right in fact
china is only threatening
us dominance in the south china sea not
the whole world
but this region it really is the most
important when it comes to international
trade
and this is why the struggle is quite so
intense
but the show it still goes on
[Music]
in fact china knows that if it goes too
far with building military bases the u.s
will call on its allies in the region to
do the same
this would mean scaling up military
spending and look china and the u.s they
might not be the best couple on the
planet
but they kind of tolerate each other and
also the us's allies in the region well
they
really do have a problem with china
we've got india which we mentioned
previously there's also japan among
others and china does not want those
guys to increase their military presence
this is why so far china is playing a
very patient
game it's a very long term challenge and
long term
in chinese that means really long term
we might be talking about
decades here but despite the slow path
you'd
better remember the term string of
pearls because it's going to appear
a lot more in the newspapers
this is going to be so important at the
beginning of next year on visualpolitik
we're going to
continue telling you more about it in
another series of videos that we've got
coming up so if you don't want to miss
those please do not forget to subscribe
to this channel
and hit that bell button so you won't
miss any posts but now the question is
do you think that the string of pearls
is
really such a threat to international
stability where does the u.s
go from here is this the beginning of
the end
for the american empire well please
leave your answer in the comment section
below
and of course don't forget to visit our
friends from reconsider media.com
they're the podcasts that provided the
vocals in this episode that were not
mine
also if you like this video give it a
like and as always
i'll see you next time and if you want
to learn more about politics and hear
even more of my lovely voice you can
join us at reconsider media
we have a podcast at reconsider
media.com
podcast see you there